like men understand
that really in all honesty when you
think about it all men are in desperate
times when you think about it when you
think about it all men have really
adapted to the times okay because a
hundred years ago what would the man so
the man would come to the table and he
said here's your protection here's your
provisioning now a hundred years later
men still by and large outer in women
and still by and large run society and
they run all of the mechanisms that
protect women in society so women are
still getting the protection and
provisioning and before the men would
get like five kids out of the deal and
exchange they would get a virgin or at
least a chick that hadn't slept with
like I mean 85 percent of women said
they were virgins on their wedding night
let's just say some were lying